[Music]
you know that someone is standing
outside your door when you hear the
doorbell the sound of the doorbell
traveled to you can you guess how it
traveled it travels through air yes here
the medium of propagation is a sound
requires a medium for propagation is the
medium always a not necessarily the
medium of propagation of sound can be
solids liquids or gases yes sound can
also travel through solids and liquids
before we get to that let us see some
other examples of sound propagating
through air remember air is nothing but
a mixture of gases sound of the siren
when the train is approaching you sound
of glass breaking sound of the
Firecracker etc are some of the examples
where the medium of propagation is air
sound can also propagate through liquids
let us do one experiment to see this we
place the bell in the water like this so
that it does not touch the base of the
container now keep one of your ears
close to the surface of water and shake
the Bell inside do you hear the sound
yes you do hear the medium of
propagation is water what instrument
does the doctor use to check the rate of
your heartbeat yes it's called a
stethoscope doctors place the small
disks shaped object called a turnable
diaphragm against your chest the sound
of your heartbeat travels through the
tube and can be heard from the to hear
pieces so can you guess the medium of
propagation of sound here yes here the
medium of propagation is a solid the
tube through which the sound travels is
the solid now suppose you're standing on
one side of a brick wall and your friend
on another side with one of his ears
close to the surface of the wall hit the
wall with some wooden object ask your
friend if he hears the sound on the
opposite side
I'm sure he will say yes here the medium
of propagation is again a solid so with
the help of a few examples we saw that
sound can travel through solids liquids
and gases but does it mean that sound
can travel through anything and
everything
the answer is resounding no the sound
cannot travel through vacuum what is the
vacuum it is a space from where all or
most of the matter is removed example is
outer space yes we cannot hear sound in
outer space that is why they say in
space no one can hear you scream in the
next video we are going to talk about
some important properties of sound known
as amplitude and frequency see you there